you deserve to be recognized but  sometimes people omit your name did they  snub you or was it an honest mistake  with 10 probability the judge is a hater  and otherwise the judge is fair a hater  will always omit you a fair judge is not  perfect 10 of the time the judge omits  you by an honest mistake otherwise you  will be included if you are omitted from  the list what is the chance the judge  was a hater to solve this problem we  will work out a tree with all of the  different possibilities we then need to  calculate the probabilities of the  branches where you were omitted this  will be 0.1 for being a hater and will  be 0.9 times 0.1 which equals 0.09 for  the fair Branch so the total sum of  these is 0.19 and the branch of being a  hater divided by that will be 0.1  divided by 0.19 which is equal to 10  over 19 or approximately 52.6 percent  you can't be sure they're hater but  chances are they were